allez on a parlé université on va
descendre d'un petit échelon on va
parler révision et notamment révision au
baccalauréat alors l'association archimè
de voisin le Bretonneux existe depuis
1990 et à chaque vacances scolaire c'est
un peu le même rituel Catherine bedog
j'ai envie de dire puisque c'est le
temps c'est le temps des révisions vous
organisez des ateliers notamment en math
en français ou encore en anglais en ce
moment à la Maison des Associations donc
à voisin il y a beaucoup de de lycéen
reçu là pour cette ces vacances il y a
toujours pas mal de lycéens au moment de
pâqu euh pour les matières scientifiques
les maths et la physique d'autres en en
français pour les années du bac français
la première quelques collégiens aussi
qui soit essayent de progresser un peu
avant la fin de l'année soit prépare un
peu le brevet voilà ou al là c'est la
dernière la première épreuve de de
baccalauréat ça sera la philo ce sera le
17 juin j'ai envie de vous demander
est-ce que c'est trop tard pour entamer
ces révisions si vraiment on n' pas du
tout
révisé c SAU si on n pas du tout révisé
ben évidemment c'est un peu une évidence
de dire qu'il est grand temps de s'y
mettre mais bon d'une manière générale
j'ai envie de dire peut-être en
préambule que rien n'est jamais perdu
parce qu'au fond ces jeunes ils nous
étonnent parfois nous-même ils ont des
capacités insoupçonnées et quand ils se
mettent au travail les les ceux qui
travaillent le moins sont parfois très
surprenants en même temps on peut quand
même donner un conseil général c'est une
régularité du rythme de travail ça reste
vrai mais c'est vrai que j'is env dit un
peu en prmobile rien n'est jamais perdu
si bon il faut avoir vraiment une espèce
de rage de réussir surtout si on n' pas
assez travaillé mais rien n'est jamais
complètement gagné également
c'est-à-dire que faut pas partir trop
parce voilà on a eu on a eu des notes
correctes bon c'est je veux dire voilà
il y a il y a toujours le côté examen on
peut se tomber sur un sujet qui
convienne moins voilà donc c'est aussi
au moral c'est important quoi cette
espèce de rage de vaincre le moral et la
confiance hein voilà et donc une partie
des stages c'est vrai que les stages là
c'est un temps privilégié bon il
commence un petit peu le stress monte un
peu quand même chez un certain nombre
donc c'est vrai que d'être avec
quelqu'un de qualifiés parce que nos
intervenants sont des professeurs donc
vraiment il voi passer des générations
de d'élèves qui vont préparer le B on va
parler un petit peu de comment
s'organiser s ateliers mais d'abord
est-ce qu'il y a une façon ou un conseil
que vous pourriez donner justement parce
que vous connaissez bien le sujet sur la
façon de bien organiser ces ces révision
voilà alors est qu' faut est-ce qu'il
faut qu'on commence par exemple je vous
coupe par les matières qu'on aime le
plus ou les matières qu'on aime le moins
ou est-ce qu'il faut faire des révisions
par ordre chronologique de la date
d'examen est-ce qu'il y a une petite
méthode moi moi je dirais que j'ai pour
moi-même je me suis fait un peu une
synthèse de qu quel genre de conseil on
peut donner pour aller du plus général
au plus particulier puis je réponds à
votre question tout de suite après mais
je voudrais pas négliger l'aspect
général enfin ce que je dis l'aspect
général c'est l'aspect hygiène de vie
c'est-à-dire que nos jeunes bon pour les
pratiquer certains nous nous avons
pratiqué les nôtres à la maison ça fait
déjà quelques années mais quand même les
souvenirs sont bien voilà et ils ont est
ce que nous ont rappelé puisque nous en
parlons aussi avec l'équipe des
professeurs c'est que il faut adopter
une hygiène de vie c'est-à-dire un
rythme assez régulier le corps prend ses
habitudes il ne faut pas croire alors
c'est vrai que certains travaillent
mieux notamment en vacances entre ils
vont dormir jusqu'à min midi après ils
vont travailler 2h enfin sûrement pas
jusqu'à 10h le soir mais par étape ne
révons pas mais voilà quoi et après on
va refaire autre chose se détendre se
coucher à 2h du matin mais le corps
prend ses habitudes et on vaut pas
forcément être frais le 17 a juin entre
8h et 13h parce qu'on on s'est habitué
et donc il faut retrouver une hygiène de
vie c'est-à-dire dormir aux heures de
nuit et et être réveillé aux Hees de
jour déjà c'est la première base et
après effectivement un rythme de travail
assez régulier c'est-à-dire dans les
semaines qui restent pour parler des des
conseils très généraux dans les semaines
qui restent bah il y a un programme il
voit bien les matières scientifiques il
y a des chapitres il faut les diviser
dans les nombres de semaine et se dire
il y aura des points de passage sur
telle semaine il faut que j'ai vu ça et
ça et découper parce que sinon faut pas
croire que dans les dernières semaines
ils vont travailler 10h par jour on
n'est pas efficace 10 he par jour même
si on a une capacité de donc au
niveau des choix par contre des matières
on choix des matières je dirais par
exemple à la période de vacance une
matière qu'on aime pas par exemple bah
oui bien sûr on peut pas faire ça
pendant 5h de suite mais je dirais que
certainement une des stratégies qui
paraissent fonctionner plutôt pas mal
c'est que si on se dit dans les vacances
qu'on essaie de mettre un bon coup
surtout si on a pas fait tout à fait ce
qu'il faut bon jusque là ça serait
peut-être de se dire j'essaie de
consacrer ça 5 he par jour c'est pas
tellement la peine d'aller au-delà parce
qu'on sera pas efficace avec peut-être
des périodes et des pauses mais dans ces
5 he on va pas faire 5 he de map ou 5h
de physique donc essayer de se dire je
consacre 2 heures à telle matière et
puis je prends une autre qui me plaît
moins et puis j'ai varie avec une trème
parce que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
arrivera à rester mobilisé c'est-à-dire
si on essaie de se mettre des formules
dans la tête
ou je je fais les maths et la physique P
de semaines ça va être insortable voàis
qu'il faut varier quoi comme activité et
puis ne pas négliger aussi le fait on a
dit manger équilibré et puis bouger un
peu on va pas rester 5h assis quoi c'est
vrai que bon on en reparlera sur la
gestion de l'examen je me suis fait un
peu des des paou vousz vousz bien on va
faire une première pause dans C dans cet
entretien nous sommes allés justement
dans les rues de 50 pour demander aux
habitants un peu leur souvenir de
révision de bac on va écouter leur
réponse et je précise quand même que
c'est c'est un panel qui est pas
forcément représentatif on va quand même
écouter leur réponse je l'ai un peu
passé sans réviser donc voilà ça m'a pas
empêché de l'avir mais
trop bien en maison de campagne je me
souviens d'avoir révisé de Gaulles près
d'une Mar et j'allais plonger dans la
mar dès que j'en avais marre et j'en
avais souvent marre j'ai pas révisé pour
les examens j'ai fini les cours j'ai
fait la fête pendant de semaines j'ai
passé mes examens et je eu ouais ben
vacances gâché
et voilà j'ai fait l'impasse sur les 3/4
du programme j'enai étudié qu'un quart
parce
que je me suis dit qu'on aurait de toute
façon une question ce qui sur
le général sur le monde j'ai quand même
tremblé pendant une bonne un bon quart
d'heure en me demandant ce que j'allais
prendre parce que je savais rien du
reste mois c'était l'année dernière et
euh c'était très intense alors là il y a
prescription bon il y a une jeunes
filles qui disent c'était très intense
il y en a qui disent j'ai pas du tout
révisé ça c'est pas un conseil à donner
par contre il y a une jeune femme qui
parlait des révisions tour de de gale et
qui dit moi en fait je me baignais dans
la mar pour un peu faire un
dis il faut bouger aussi il faut
continuer une activité sportive ù ça
peut être marcher ça peut être aller
courir ça peut être aller au cinéma mais
se détendre c'est vrai que bon souvent
on a quand même plutôt le conseil à leur
donner de travailler sérieusement parce
alors travaille sérieusement et puis il
y a une dame aussi qu'on a interviewé
qui nous dit moi j'avais révisé qu'un
quart du programme alors est-ce que
c'est une stratégie moi je la trouve
dangereuse très très mauvais conseil
c'est très très rare mais il y a quand
même toujours des élèves qui font des
impasses il y aussi quelques professeurs
qui n'avaient pas pu tout faire et
malheureusement les impasses ça tombent
un jour ou l'autre donc c'est vraiment
pas un bon conseil ça les conseils qu'on
peut donner quelques jours avant
l'épreuve on n est pas encore c'est au
mois de juin mais quelques jours avant
l'épreuves qu'est-ce qu'on peut donner
comme conseil et puis après vous nous
direz pendant lesépreuve voilà on a vu
on a vu là il reste quelques semaines
donc on a vu l'aspect il y a une masse
de travail fournir un programme à
découper essayer de se faire des points
de passage donc découper en nombre de
semaines et se dire tant tant de choses
à faire par semaine he que ce soit tel
programme ça c'est une chose après je
dirais par matière il y a une un certain
nombre de choses qui sont très simples à
rappeler c'est-à-dire pour avoir discuté
et vu travailler nos professeurs
notamment dans les matières
scientifiques mais ça n'est sûrement pas
la vrai que là il y a des choses
extrêmement simples c'est que les élèves
enfin un certain nombre gagneraient à
travailler et à apprendre vraiment leurs
cours ne pas croire qu'en rentrant des
formules dans les calculatrices on va s'
s'en sortir c'est assez rare qu'il s'en
sorte parce qu'ils sont pas toujours
capable de bien les retrouver et puis
apprendre le cours et faire des fiches
de synthèse c'est vrai que ce sont des
mots qu'ils ont entendu et des choses
qu'ils ont entendu dire par leurs
parents il ça le ça leur parle pas
beaucoup souvent ça a quand même une
vertu c'est que pour une fiche pour
faire une fiche de synthèse on est
obligé à l'essenti et puis il faut
réfléchir à ce qu'on a comprendre voilà
faut bien déjà faire un tri dans le
cours bon il y a des il y a quand même
certaines définitions propriété
essentiell le fait de les écrire après
chacun doit trouver comment il
fonctionne il y a des gens qui vont plus
retenir en lisant parce que ils ont
mémoire plus visuelle il y a des gens
qui vont plus retenir en marchant disant
les choses parce que c'est plus auditif
bon après à chacun Tess de se trouver
ses moyens mais en tout cas ça c'est je
veux dire il y a point ça c'est ça fait
partie des incontournables il faut
absolument qu'ils sachent leur cours
d'accord j le jour de l'épreuve appr
prendre son cours quand même pour finir
avec cette idée c'est aussi notamment
les matières scientifiques se faire des
petits exercices d'application direct il
y en a dans les livres dans les anales
bien sûr pour être sûr que on croit
avoir ais on croit avoir compris mais
quand on se met en situation ils ont
plein de corriger voir si on est capable
de le faire quoi c'est pas la peine
d'aller se lancer sur des bacs et des
choses plus difficiles plus élaboré si
déjà les premiers exercices
d'application on peut travailler de
façon autonome quand même quel que soit
son niveau après effectivement pendant
lesépreuves on arrive on est devant la
feuille avec les sujets d'examen c'est
la panique évidemment la panique alors
il faut quand même dire aussi des
vérités simples c'est que si on est
préparé à 200 % on a moins de raison de
paniquer si on est préparé à 30 % le
stress la G du stress après le stress
c'est vrai qu'on est inégau face à ça
ouais parenthèse sur la G du stress
parce qu'il a quand même des techniques
de relaxation moi pour ce qui me
concerne je connais bien la relaxation
active méthode martenau parce que je la
pratique et je l'enseigne en quelques
mots alors en quelques mots c'est oui je
pas trop faire mais enfin pourquoi pas
faire la pub parce que les adultes
connaissent on a quand même un certain
nombre de cours au voisin Montini
association pH pH est dans les guides de
voisin mon et mais c'est une technique
qui se fait en tout petit groupe il y a
donc des petits mouvements il y a des
petites choses très simples comme h bof
et là chez épaules parce que il y a
plein de tensions qui se mettent là il y
a l'observation de la respiration
naturelle quand on est face pour revenir
à votre question précise alors ces
techniqu là bien sûr il y en a d'autres
moi je parle de celle que je connais et
qui convient à un certain nombre moi qui
me réussi je trouve pas trop mal plutôt
bien et donc quand on est face à une
épreuve bien sûr que ces techniques a
d'autres qui sont sérieuses si on va
chercher d'autres techniques dans la
station il faut être sûr que c'est
quelque chose de sérieux elle fonctionne
mieux si on a déjà un petit peu
d'entraînement c'est comme pour tout he
on découvre ça 3 jours l'examen ça
marche moins que si on l'a déjà fait
pendant un trimestre mais il n'est pas
trop tard pour venir tester et donc il y
a notamment un petit temps d'arrêt enfin
bon ça c'est des mots qu'on emploie dans
nos cours ceux qui suivent nos cours sil
m'entendent on se reconnaîent un petit
temps d'arrêt c'est-à-dire on est en
train de distribuer les sujets et cetera
profiter pour être là fermer ses yeux
simplement se mettre là là où ça respire
se dire je suis vraiment je suis tout à
moi j'oublie ce qu' autour voilà c'est
je suis pas en train de me dire oh là là
si ça tombe sur C chapitre machin là et
là le stress monte et c'est affreux il y
a des gens ça peut leur faire perdre 50
% de leur moyen si on se met dans sa
respiration dis en se disant voilà là ça
respire ça respire tout seul et je suis
simplement à l'écoute de ce qui se passe
des choses toutes simples ou bien mes
contacts mes pieds comment je suis
déposer sur mon siège et puis je
m'installe voilà une bonne position dans
l'axe la verticalité et puis bof c'est
petit lâcher les PE qu'on toujour faire
c'est pas grave conseil de relaxation
deel voilà et c'est vraiment pas
négligeable et puis ça comme une tu bon
pour aller quand même à l'essentiel par
3 He là-dessus c'est que quand on est là
sur ce qui se passe en nous on a un
petit peu arrêté ce moulin à parole qui
va nous stresser et voilà ça sert à rien
quoi d'accord mais merci en tout cas
pour tous les conseils que vous nous
avez prodigué votre association je l'ai
dit existe depuis 90 vous organiser des
ateliers spécifiquement pendant les
vacances scolaires et hors des vacances
il y aura aussi également dans les
derniers jours là la dernière semaine
avant le bac où ils sont libérés en
généralement nous proposons encore
quelques séances de révision ça ne
remplace pas un travail régulier régul
et on va pas avoir le temps de finir
mais on a bien compris donc régularité
et bonne hygiène de vie aussi pour être
prêt le jour de
l'examen les fuses techniques de
respiration de Catherine bodock pour
pour se libérer du Strep merci beaucoup
d'être venu en plateau